freunde wunderschönen guten morgen ich
habe letztens sushi von steffen henssler
getestet das hat uns sehr gut gefallen
mir auch und steffen henssler ist auch
bekannt für seine schnellen rezepte für
die schnelle nummer und das machen wir
heute einen tag lang ich koche einen tag
lang schnelle nummern zettel von steffen
henssler hier habe ich schon das
frühstück auch in der moderation ich bin
einfach heute stellen wir haben ein post
wo wir haben sechs eier größe m rote
zwiebeln chili koriander fritzsche und
olivenöl und was wir machen ist ein
california -star sandwich sollte erst
zumindest gelangt merkt ihr probiert
aber mal so viel wie und einfach auf
einen durchgegeben ein bisschen öl in
die pfanne hat er so gesagt und hat dann
über das 4 1 gemacht was erst mal
sympathisch ist muss ich sagen dann hat
steffens noch nicht direkt gemacht ich
mache es aber jetzt schon die ränder
abgeschnitten weil sonst später
wahrscheinlich zu wenig platz in der
pfanne sein wird und wieder gesagt hat
ist das auch sehr gut für die zahllosen
pflegen wir mal hier hinein das saugt
sich halte ich mich komplett folgende öl
aber ist der kalifornier schnelles
jahren amerikanische dann haben wir uns
einen messbecher und echt gespannt auf
zu testen wie schnell die rezepte
wirklich sind also die lecker sie sehen
wenn ihr seht schon sehr populistische
zutaten aus rheydt sind wahrscheinlich
wenig raum den gesamten tag über für so
kleine koch handke so sachen wie
manchmal den unterschied machen wo man
so 80 prozent mehr arbeit für 20 prozent
mehr ergebnis aber ich bin sicher das
wird trotzdem lecker die frage ist nur
wie länger dann jede menge koriander ein
grund hat er gesagt ungefähr so viel
machen wir mal sondern und den hat er
dann schön fein geschnitten die zwiebel
sitzung gleich schön freien würfen und
dann nehmen wir uns hier eine chillige
ich nämlich schön große und die
schneiden wir auch und gehen jetzt alles
und weil das ganze noch nicht genug es
kommen jetzt zwei
jetzt von unserer chilisoße einander
geweckt ich werde natürlich die original
die wir uns auf der linken wenn ihr euch
das im original noch mal anschauen
wollte er seine beschreibung das ganz
gut auch kriegt langsam fahren sondern
sehen uns recht unser großes anderer
stift jetzt gehen die hälfte von unserer
eigentlich und in die pfanne in einem
älteren gebühren reichen
gehen wir mit einem kleinen fest jetzt
wenn das ganze leben noch so leicht
flüssig ist geben wir an eine schöne
ecke so pops und jetzt wollen wir das
ganze einmal gegenüber von der anderen
seite dann kommt große seite thierry
henry von excel witch ja
das ganze halbieren wir noch einmal es
war mit schnelle nummer euro also zehn
minuten in die wahrscheinlichkeit einer
unserer kürzesten drehs für eine
mahlzeit wenn es jetzt auch noch
schmeckt bei der aufwand war wirklich
marginal das ist eine geile sache
steffen henzel hat das immer gegessen
als er eine sushi roller ausbildung
gemacht hat in los angeles ist kann ich
mir gut vorstellen dass er daran gute
erinnerungen hat aber ich probiere es
erst mal selbst
ich kann sehr gut verstehen warum es das
los angeles gibt ich war ja auch schon
worden das ist für mich schon fast so
ein bisschen so der der beiden der stadt
so was frisches so eine gewisse hitze da
das ist auch so ein ding du frühstück
stars und die kann es eigentlich
wirklich nicht schlecht gehen
[Gelächter]
richtig es ist trotzdem geiles schnelles
einfaches frühstück und auch so ein
bisschen so ein sympathischer tag auf
diese sticks mbit/s wahrscheinlich so
der vater von ticketscript dort sind das
omelett ist wirklich sehr sehr flüssig
hat innen drin auch so eine gewisse
sachlichkeit welche aber ein bisschen
was kann der röstung des brots wegnimmt
also ist bleibt nicht mehr so super
knusprig da android trotzdem geil das
frühstück schnelle nummer geschmacklich
würde ich sagen acht von zehn was
wirklich sehr sehr gut ist und ich freue
mich auf die nächste mahlzeit vor allem
in acht von zehn für solch einen
geringen aufwand okay dass ihr es sich
auch und wird sagen da sehen wir uns
schon zum mittagessen direkt wieder und
jetzt gibt es eine pastoren nicht
irgendeine sondern wir machen eine
brokkoli passt damit kann schaeffler mit
getrockneten tomaten mit knoblauch und
das ganze ist etwas was sie noch nie so
gegessen oder gemacht habe deshalb bin
ich sehr gespannt jemand in unserer
pfanne ein wenig von uns olivenöl also
und wieder fiel die wahl wirklich
geliefert wird dieses mal sagt steffen
dass es liebe ist und heizen wie mal
langsam form so dass interessante bei
dieser pasta ist dass wir den blumenkohl
ich im ganzen verwenden sondern dass wir
ihn rasieren was sehr sehr gut
funktioniert hat das wetter noch mal
geschäft funktioniert 1a und genau so
sollen wir das jetzt auch machen wie
rasieren erstmal weiter also dass wir
quasi so diese kleinen blumen kuriosen
allesamt ab schnibbeln sondern geben
jetzt in unsere fahne nach unsere
pancetta beziehungsweise in dem fall
einfach bauchspeck ich extra so ein
bisschen kreuz und quer geschnitten dass
zu diesen can't make hat dazu geben wir
dann getrocknete tomaten gestückelt und
das ist so ein motiv bei der schnellen
gemacht so der steffen henssler macht
gar nicht so extra alles so perfekt und
point angedünstet
angefärbt oder sonst hat das muss
schnell gehen also der haut dann auch
wenig pancetta noch gar nicht fertig ist
oder schon mal den knoblauch dazu und
dann komplett abgerufen
würde ich mal wieder so ein schönes
kleines aber feines das bka schon einige
getrocknete tomaten sind natürlich auch
so absolute geschmacks unten und dann
nehmen wir auch unseren brokkoli
und eben dazu und sie dürften jetzt auch
mit an
hier klappt wurden noch mal eine gute
ecke mehr von diesen bildern
werden das alles gehandelt wird geht der
trübe des wassers
olivenöl verschwindet in den rockies
gleichzeitig werden wir gleich
beobachten können dass ein bisschen was
heraus kommt jetzt schon wie das sehr
sehr gut aus dann würde ich sagen ein
bisschen farbe bekommen das niemals so
die
migros gelehrt haben bekommen genau ist
weniger geworden würde ich sagen in der
masse zu dieser spinat effekt das ist
einfach so verantwortung so oft wir
müssen jetzt ganz wenig aber wir sehen
auch richter ist so viel olivenöl
nochmal rein gekommen das muss auch so
sein weil es sind ja sagt steffen auch
im prinzip spaghetti aglio e olio mit
blumen kräutern und jetzt den wir hier
einmal hinein sehen schon das wasser das
leicht trüb von der stärke die nudeln
abgegeben haben und geben dass jetzt die
einmal hin zu zwei kernen erstmal schon
richtig gut aus jetzt bildet sich aus
wirklich so eine richtige substanz hat
schon eine schöne salz note von der
pancetta das aber nicht fehlen darf so
ein bisschen pepp und
pfeffermühle leer ist aber kein problem
ich kann eigentlich einpacken und werden
die nudeln jetzt hier ein bisschen
fertig garen kann ich euch von kobo
erzählen co macht nämlich nicht nur so
wunderbare ein kilogramm tüten schwarzer
pfeffer sondern generell große portion
fair produziert in guter qualität und
das gute an diesen großen packen was ist
unter anderem zb das natürlich weniger
verpackungsmüll hat pro kauf hofft kann
ich damit meine müde nach es gab mal
eine zeit als ich wirklich jedes mal
wenn ich gebraucht haben so einen dicken
videoformat gekauft aber damit dass
vorgesorgt meine festung ist sowieso ein
kollektor richtig weiß sieht auch eine
gta bongo werdet ihr wahrscheinlich dann
über die nächsten wochen und monaten
noch ein bisschen besser kennen lernt
man kennt jeden fall groß und kurz dass
ihr mich unterstützt
irgendwie passte ausziehen bitte also
wirklich bildhübsch ich sicher ich sehe
natürlich hier aus sieht es richtig gut
aus klar da ist jetzt mit gute ecke
olivenöl dran nichtsdestotrotz habe ich
noch eine ganz runde geschichte ich
dinge die jetzt auf dem schönen keller
wo wir das kann suchen wenig von einem
schwarzen pfeffer darüber sollte wenn
ihr das ganze mal probieren wollte mit
meinem kopf max 15,5 prozent auf die
sowieso gemindert und weise kommt
nämlich die preise ein bisschen tiefer
gemacht weil die leute sowieso schon
inflation genug gebeutelt sind ja wir
haben eine wunderschöne passt da die
null komma nichts gemacht wir gehen
einmal rein sie sehen schon jetzt ein
glanz die passt also da ist auf jeden
fall ausreichend öl dran ein bisschen
von brokkoli tten von speck
[Musik]
hochuli bringt mehr geschmack sein als
man denken oder schmeckt eindeutig nach
buckow die pasta und jetzt mir das neue
linke noch nicht unbedingt vorstellen
können meinte gerade zumal ich das schon
des öfteren gegessen haben dass sogar
eine mit meiner lieblings kostet mit
weil ich verstehe aber um seine
lieblings vater sein kann weil es
einfach so spart man sich so zu essen
also eine partei wie man sie schaufeln
man sieht hier richtig schön wie der
brokkoli mit den kleinen knospen
mächtigen kleinen rosen so in die pasta
eingebogen ist und das kriegt man durch
nur dadurch dass man ihn so basiert nur
in acht von zehn gesagt was sagst du
jetzt beim mittagessen geht es einfach
ein hoch neun von zehn verhältnis
aufwand geschmack ist wirklich krass
also sehr nett ist nicht wirklich auch
wieder zehn minuten gebraucht ich hätte
nur vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr
knoblauch drin haben können ob ich meine
bisschen mehr knoblauch ein bisschen
chili hat keines aber dann wäre es eine
noch klar es hätte noch eine klassische
allgäu note gehabt nichtsdestotrotz sehr
sehr köstlich und auf jeden fall eine
erweiterung für das passte für touren
nächste mahlzeit letzte mahlzeit wir
machen blumenkohl stakes zwangsweise
blumen schnitzel aber am ende des tages
wahrscheinlich genau das gleiche auch
wieder ein flottes rezept trotzdem das
aufwendigste das wir heute haben mir ein
wunderbar vorbereitet und wir gucken uns
die mit hier kann man ein schönes
durchgängig sehr gut hier drüben und
schreibe dann quasi links und rechts
haben wir runter
gemacht dann daraus ein schönes also
einen halb daumenbreite stack ganz so
wieder steffen ist auch gemacht hat
produktideen jetzt den blumenkohl so wie
er ist erst mal für sechs minuten in
salzwasser das kopf hätten schon und da
kam mir das ganze erstmal brauchen auch
weil er schnell noch mal zeit zum
ausspannen sein und butter dünsten wir
hier eine zwiebel an und geben direkt zu
unserer zwiebeln ist übrigens eine ganze
weiße zwiebel ein wenig früh pulver also
einfach in gespür und jetzt kommt schon
das ganze bildet nämlich recht unsere
soße wir machen sennestadt mittel schafe
sind und wenn das konzipiert und ist von
uns ein bisschen von unserem blumenkohl
was ist schon gesetzt also wird ein
bisschen salz wird hinein und kultischen
handlungen vorgeschmack und
findet die ganze so präsent löst sich
halt dann jetzt gleich hier sind aber es
ist überhaupt erst mal aus weil die
davor hat dass es gar nicht gelöst
verbindet sich mit dem ganzen jetzt
gehen wir dazu den saft von einer halben
zitrone
die dafür die spalte geschnitten aber
das ganze gleich mit einem klick stadt
durchziehen was eigentlich film dass ich
das in der pfanne gemacht habe wir geben
uns deshalb über unseren saucen top wenn
das hier so vor sich hin blubbert dann
sieht man sogar schon sondern leichte
dicke das ganze also wie es blubbert da
merkt man es schon in der presse so
fordere hin blubbert wir noch ein wenig
sahne dazu das kriegt das ganze ein gib
mir noch mehr geschmack
fertig
das vorsichtig mit sondern silikon zwang
heraus und wenn es abgedruckt ist geben
wir das hier in unserer doppelt
richtiges medien ein erste station in
der pannierstraße quasi wenn wir das
ganze einmal vielleicht spaß von vorne
um auch noch
so geben wir hätten uns etwas öl war
leicht am rauchen das verrät uns das ist
die perfekte temperatur hat und so
packen wir es jetzt von beiden seiten
goldbraun
und wenn man darunter
der sich
nicht mit uns ist so ein richtiges
holzfäller steak holzfäller innen steak
nama mehr gegeben es hinüber wenig soße
außenrum wird auch wichtig seien große
zeh durch gar nicht im klassischen mit
im schnitt
könnten otok denken das ist so schicken
ist auch oder so ein bisschen ja
bisschen zu viel
ich schneide mir meine ecke ab schneidet
sich super auch wichtig dass man das
ganze vorgegangen war übelst schicken
die sich aus jetzt wo das gesagt hast ja
ich bin sehr gespannt ich habe mir echt
sorgen dafür dass es viel zu heiß ist es
geschafft und ist nicht vollends
verwarnt aber die zitrus notwehr so
fällt es sehr sehr krass auch die textur
kommt überraschend nahe hans steak also
dass man so aus eine kleine kursdaten
und so war das schon echte pferde und
käfer auf kalorien betrachtet so ein
blumenkohl steht ja fast nur aus wasser
wirklich überraschend gut trotzdem ich
so gut wie die brocken hin und für mich
ich habe ihm auch wieder eine acht von
zehn die woche die nudeln bahn übrigens
mit ein bisschen chillen ist und zitrone
zählt für mich also die waren wirklich
sehr sehr gut die kann ich jedem
empfehlen die anderen gerichte aber auch
vielen dank an stephen hester dass er
seine gerichte teilt wie gesagt alles
verlinkt und sind zunächst mal wieder
was hat euch gefallen die sind wirklich
alle werten achten kommt zu werden und
sie gehen wirklich so schnell